Quelle est la couleur de la neige ?
Et la couleur de la crème chantilly ?
Du coton ?
Que boit la vache ?
Si vous avez répondu "du lait" à cette dernière question vous êtes tombé dans le panneau,
et vous venez d'être victime d'un effet d'amorçage.
Bah oui les vaches ça boit de l'eau en fait.
L'amorçage c'est quand, d'une manière ou d'une autre, on vous met dans certaines dispositions qui vont influencer vos choix.
Ici le fait de vous faire penser de façon répétée au blanc
a augmenté la probabilité que vous répondiez "du lait" à la question de ce que buvait la vache.
L'amorçage fonctionne grâce à ce qu'on appelle notre "mémoire implicite", qui tend à faire automatiquement certaines associations.
Et on va voir que cette mémoire implicite nous expose à des formes de manipulation
mais nous permet aussi peut-être d'en savoir un peu plus sur nous mêmes
Il existe de nombreuses manières de mettre en évidence les effets d'amorçage. Une des plus classiques c'est l'exercice de complétion de mots.
Imaginez que je vous présente les lettres suivantes et que je vous demande de compléter ce mot.
Et bien si avant je vous ai parlé de guerre, de soldats, de mitrailleuses, eh bien il est plus probable que vous le complétiez en
"Char" alors que si je viens de vous parler de chiens ou de souris vous allez plutôt le compléter en "chat".
Ce que je vous présente avant de vous demander de compléter un mot peut vous amorcer, c'est à dire préparer votre cerveau à faire un
choix plutôt qu'un autre. Il existe un autre exercice un peu relié qui permet d'étudier de façon quantitative ces effets d'amorçage :
on l'appelle la reconnaissance lexicale. Le principe c'est que je vous présente une série de lettres et vous avez deux boutons :
l'un pour indiquer que ces lettres forment un mot qui existe dans la langue française
et l'autre au contraire pour répondre que ça n'est pas un mot.
Si je vous présente les lettres suivantes, bah ça n'est pas un mot donc vous appuyez à gauche
alors que ces lettres-ci en forment un, donc vous appuyez à droite.
C'est facile comme jeu ! Le truc c'est qu'il faut aller le plus vite possible et moi je mesure votre temps de réaction
et ce qu'on constate c'est par exemple que si avant l'exercice
je vous ai parlé de feuilles, de troncs, ou de forêt, eh bien au cours du test vous serez plus rapide à reconnaître que
A.R.B.R.E est effectivement un mot de la langue française.
L'effet d'amorçage va se traduire par une diminution du temps de réaction sur les mots qui sont associés.
Alors là vous allez me dire : tout ça n'est ni très surprenant ni très inquiétant : si je vous parle de forêt
évidemment votre cerveau est préparé à entendre parler d'arbres et donc il va plus vite à reconnaître ce mot quand on lui présente.
Et d'ailleurs des chercheurs ont pu montrer par des analyses IRM le mécanisme cérébral qui est derrière tout ça.
Si on réalise un amorçage, eh bien ça conduit à une réduction de l'activité cérébrale dans certaines zones qui seraient normalement impliqués dans la réponse.
En gros, l'amorçage fait que notre cerveau se concentre sur certaines choses et en met d'autres de côté
ce qui lui permet de gagner du temps dans les décisions.
Et tout ça est finalement plutôt logique et rassurant : notre cerveau optimise son fonctionnement de manière à être le plus rapide et le plus pertinent possible.
Sauf que ça peut conduire à influencer notre comportement sans qu'on s'en rende compte.
En 1996, le psychologue John Bargh a réalisé une petite série d'expériences étonnantes sur les effets d'amorçage.
Il a convié des gens à faire un test : on leur affichait des séries de cinq mots, par exemple : trouve, le, il, cache, instantanément.
Et ils devaient à chaque fois former une phrase de 4 mots parmi ces cinq, qui soit grammaticalement correcte. Par exemple ici :
"il le trouve instantanément".
On leur faisait faire ça sur trente groupes de mots et puis à la fin ont les remerciait de leur participation aux tests.
... Sauf que ça n'était pas ça le test : ça c'était juste les préliminaires. En réalité, on avait divisé au hasard les participants en deux groupes :
l'un des deux groupes avaient dans les problèmes auquel il était soumis des mots du genre :
ancien, sage,
retraité, ride : des mots en rapport avec la vieillesse.
L'autre groupe était un groupe de contrôle dont les mots étaient quelconques, du genre : voiture, propre, soif, ...
Et c'est seulement une fois l'épreuve terminée que le test commençait vraiment :
à la fin de l'exercice, les participants devaient en effet apporter leurs résultats à un chercheur situé dans une autre pièce.
Et sans qu'ils le sachent, on chronométrait le temps qu'ils mettaient à traverser le couloir pour s'y rendre.
Et ce qu'ont montré les chercheurs c'est que les participants qui avaient été amorcés avec des mots liés au concept de vieillesse
mettaient plus de temps que les autres à aller d'un bout à l'autre du couloir.
Comme si le fait d'avoir pensé à tous ces mots ralentissait leur marche.
Alors certes on peut dire que la différence était réelle mais quand même pas énorme.
Mais les chercheurs ont fait une deuxième expérience sur le même schéma avec des résultats plus tranchés cette fois.
Cette fois, les participants étaient divisés en trois groupes : un groupe qui faisait l'exercice avec des mots en rapport avec la politesse
(des mots comme : cordialement, apprécier, respect ou courtois) ; un second groupe qui à l'opposé recevait des mots comme :
agressivité, intrusion, impoli, ... ; et enfin un troisième groupe de contrôle avec des mots neutres.
Et cette fois le scénario était un petit peu différent : les participants avaient toujours comme instruction d'aller apporter leurs résultats à un autre chercheur
mais cette fois il y avait une petite mise en scène.
Au moment où le test se terminait, eh bien le chercheur censé collecter les résultats était en fait en grande discussion avec un autre individu,
qui était en fait un complice. Et ce qui était mesuré
c'est si les participants allaient oser interrompre la conversation pour pouvoir les remettre leurs résultats.
Et la mise en scène durait 10 minutes, c'est à dire que s'ils n'interrompaient pas, eh bien les participants pouvaient passer 10 minutes
à poireauter en attendant sagement que la conversation se termine.
Ce qu'ont ensuite fait les chercheurs c'est qu'ils ont comparé la proportion de gens qui avaient choisi d'interrompre la conversation
en fonction des trois groupes qu'ils avaient constitué. Parmi les gens qui n'avaient pas été amorcés,
38% ont été interrompre la discussion avant la fin. Chez ceux ayant été amorcés avec des mots évoquant la politesse, c'est seulement 18%.
Et par contre dans le groupe de ceux qui avaient été amorcés avec des mots en rapport avec l'agressivité ou l'impolitesse,
le pourcentage est monté à 62 %.
L'interprétation des auteurs c'est que l'amorçage a mis les participants dans des dispositions les conduisant à être plus ou moins
agressifs ou polis dans les interactions sociales, et à la fin ça fait quand même un sacré effet.
Quelques années plus tard, Bargh a réalisé une autre expérience tout aussi surprenante.
Il a demandé à des gens de venir participer à une soi-disant étude concernant des coussins thermiques,
qui peuvent produire du chaud et du froid et qu'on utilise parfois pour soigner des douleurs musculaires.
La moitié des participants devaient manipuler brièvement un coussin qui produisait du chaud et l'autre moitié le coussin produisait du froid.
On leur demandait de simplement donner leurs impressions, et puis on les remerciait d'avoir participé à l'étude en leur proposant une petite récompense.
Comme récompense on leur donnait le choix entre deux objets mais présentés différemment :
l'un a été proposé comme étant pour le participant lui-même et l'autre accompagné d'une mention du genre : "pour faire plaisir à un ami".
Et les chercheurs ont regardé si le fait d'avoir tenu le pack chaud ou froid avait une influence sur le choix de récompense.
Et ça n'a pas raté.
Ceux qui avaient tenu le pack chaud ont choisi
à 54% le cadeau présenté comme étant pour un ami et à 46% le cadeau présenté pour eux.
Tandis que dans le groupe froid, eh bien les proportions étaient de 25 % seulement pour un ami et 75% pour soi.
La conclusion qu'en tirent les auteurs c'est que la chaleur physique peut avoir un effet d'amorçage sur la chaleur sociale.
Du coup si vous voulez draguer allez plutôt aux sauna qu'à la patinoire...
En 1998, trois chercheurs ont eu l'idée d'utiliser ces phénomènes de mémoire implicite
non pas pour influencer le comportement des gens mais pour essayer de révéler des choses sur leurs opinions profondes.
Ils ont créé ce qu'on appelle le test d'associations implicites. Alors voici le principe :
imaginez que je vous donne deux boutons : un dans votre main gauche, un dans votre main droite.
Et que je vous présente successivement 30 mots en vous disant :
si c'est un nom de fleur vous appuyez à droite et si c'est un insecte vous appuyez à gauche.
Donc tulipe à droite ; rose droite ; guêpe gauche ; moustique gauche, etc.
Et il faut répondre le plus vite possible parce qu'on mesure votre temps de réaction.
C'est pas un exercice très difficile et les temps de réaction se trouvent en moyenne entre 550 et 600 millisecondes.
Maintenant on va faire le même exercice avec des mots ayant une connotation soit positive soit négative. Pour les mots positifs,
vous appuyez à droite et pour les mots négatifs à gauche. Donc par exemple si je vous montre amour : à droite ;
désastre : gauche ;
prison : gauche ;
cadeau : droite, etc.
Et dans ce cas là les temps de réaction moyens sont à peu près les mêmes qu'avec les fleurs et les insectes.
Bon, maintenant on va compliquer et on va mélanger les deux exercices.
C'est à dire qu'on peut voir apparaître des mots qui sont soit positifs soit négatifs, soit des insectes soit des fleurs.
Il faudra appuyer à droite quand ce sont des mots positifs ou des fleurs
et à gauche quand ce sont des mots négatifs ou des insectes.
Donc, cafard : gauche ; gentillesse : droite ; jacinthe : droite ; meurtre : gauche, etc
Alors l'exercice paraît un tout petit peu plus compliqué mais en fait les temps de réaction sont très similaires : autour de 600 millisecondes.
Maintenant on va faire une dernière variante qui va être comme la précédente mais cette fois on va croiser les catégories.
C'est à dire qu'on vous demande d'appuyer à droite pour les mots négatifs et pour les fleurs,
et à gauche pour les mots positifs et pour les insectes.
Donc plaisir : gauche ; frelons : gauche ; orchidées : droite ; agonie : droite, etc.
Et avec ces instructions les temps de réaction sont significativement plus longs : 840 millisecondes en moyenne. Est-ce que vous voyez pourquoi ?
Dans notre tête, on associe plutôt les fleurs à des choses plaisantes alors que les insectes ont un côté plutôt déplaisant.
Donc quand on nous demande de trier à droite les fleurs et les mots plaisants et à gauche les insectes et les mots déplaisants
ça nous paraît facile ; mais quand c'est l'inverse on a plus de mal.
On a des difficultés à associer les fleurs et les mots déplaisants, et associer les insectes avec les mots plaisants.
Donc les temps de réaction sont allongés.
Ce que permet de mesurer ce test c'est le degré
d'associations implicites qu'on peut faire entre des familles de concept. Et une des premières choses auxquelles les auteurs ont pensé avec ce test
c'est de l'utiliser pour voir jusqu'à quel point on peut être implicitement raciste.
Pour ça, ils ont réalisé des tests d'associations implicites en utilisant à nouveau des mots positifs ou négatifs d'une part ; et de l'autre des prénoms.
Et les prénoms étaient tous types et soit plutôt blanc, genre Shannon, Adam, Hélène ; soit typés noir ;
Aiescha, Jamel, Jasmine.
Le test se passe aux Etats-Unis, je précise, et les participants étaient tous de jeunes américains blancs.
Et là les auteurs ont pu mesurer que pour associer les prénoms blancs avec le positif et les prénoms noir avec le négatif, les temps
de réaction était autour de 700 millisecondes mais que dans l'autre sens ils étaient de 900 millisecondes en moyenne.
C'est à dire que les participants étaient plus rapides quand il s'agissait de classait Jamel avec prison et Paul avec honnêteté
que quand il fallait faire l'inverse.
Ce qui est intéressant avec ce test c'est pas tellement de montrer que le racisme existe - bon ça malheureusement on le savait déjà -
mais c'est qu'il révèle les préjugés d'une manière plus profonde que ce qu'on peut montrer avec des tests classiques.
D'habitude pour évaluer quantitativement le degré de racisme d'une personne, on lui fait passer un test où elle doit noter des affirmations du genre :
"la diversité culturelle est un problème pour notre pays" ou encore "on voit trop de noirs à la télévision".
Avec à chaque fois des choix du genre "d'accord", "pas d'accord", "tout à fait d'accord", etc. C'est ce qu'on appelle un test explicite.
Ce qu'ont montré les auteurs c'est que le test d'associations implicites
révélait des biais racistes même chez ceux qui ne ressortaient pas spécialement comme racistes dans les tests explicites.
Si ça vous intéresse de faire le test, sachez que les auteurs ont mis en place un site Web qui va vous permettre
de le faire, et les résultats risquent de vous surprendre.
Alors est-ce qu on serait tous implicitement racistes ?
Alors, rassurez vous : non il faut faire un peu attention aux interprétations de ce test.
La première chose à savoir c'est qu'il a une assez forte variabilité intrinsèque,
c'est à dire que si vous le passiez plusieurs fois vous pourriez obtenir un score assez différent d'une fois sur l'autre.
Il faut donc considérer les résultats au niveau
statistique d'un groupe et pas juste d'un individu. En clair, ce test n'est pas un diagnostic pour savoir si vous spécifiquement vous êtes raciste.
L'autre point essentiel c'est que les chercheurs se sont rendus compte que même par exemple chez les noirs américains,
on pouvait retrouver des personnes qui d'après le test avaient un biais contre les noirs, ce qui est quand même un peu étonnant.
La critique de ce test a notamment été faite par d'autres scientifiques dans un article intitulé :
"Est-ce que Jesse Jackson aurait échoué aux tests d'associations implicites ?"
Jesse Jackson c'est un pasteur noir américain qui était militant pour les droits civiques, un disciple de Martin Luther King,
et qui un jour a déclaré - je vais vous traduire approximativement -
"Il n'y a rien de plus douloureux pour moi à cette étape de ma vie que de marcher dans la rue,
d'entendre des pas derrière moi, de penser à un voleur, puis de regarder, de voir que c'est un blanc et de me sentir rassuré."
Bref, ce qu'estiment certains chercheurs c'est que le test l'association implicite ne mesure pas tant le niveau de racisme d'une personne
que son degré de familiarité avec les préjugés et les stéréotypes racistes.
Ce serait donc plus une mesure d'exposition à un contexte social raciste qu'un indicateur
individuel de racisme. Un point qui tend à confirmer cette interprétation c'est que très peu d'études ont été capables de mettre en évidence
un lien entre le score au test d'associations implicites et le fait de se comporter
effectivement de façon racist. Et donc ça paraît un peu exagéré de dire de quelqu'un qu'il aurait des préjugés racistes
si ça ne se traduit jamais dans les faits, dans ses paroles ou dans ses actes.
Malgré tout il y a une étude qui a été publiée très récemment
et qui tend à montrer que certains de ces effets assez subtils peuvent exister.
L'étude s'est déroulée dans les supermarchés d'une enseigne de grande distribution française,
et l'idée c'était d'étudier comment la performance des caissiers et des caissières d'origine nord-africaine ou subsaharienne
pouvait être affectée par les éventuels biais racistes de leur manager. Pour cela, les chercheurs ont collecté des données sur 34 magasins :
ça concernait la performance de plus de 200 employés, donc par exemple leur vitesse pour scanner ou leur taux d'absentéisme,
et pendant le même temps ils ont fait passer le test d'associations implicites à leurs managers.
Il y a un point de méthodologie essentiel : en fait, chaque jour les employés sont affectés
aléatoirement aux managers. Donc ça représente des tas de combinaisons possibles pour lesquels on a pu mesurer la performance d'un jour sur l'autre.
Et ce qui a été montré c'est que les jours où les employés tombaient sur un manager ayant des préjugés racistes,
eh bien leurs performances baissaient. Ca peut paraître un peu évident comme conclusion, mais là où l'étude devient extrêmement intéressante
c'est qu'il s'avère que cette baisse de performance n'est pas liée à une forme de racisme explicite.
Les caissiers et les caissières ne se plaignaient pas d'attitudes racistes de la part des managers
et ils avaient même tendance à moins se souvenir des managers qui apparaissaient comme les plus biaisés d'après le test.
L'interprétation des auteurs c'est que les préjugés racistes
implicites des managers les conduisaient simplement
à moins interagir avec les employés d'origine nord-africaine ou sub-saharienne, et que c'est ça qui conduisait à une baisse de leurs performances.
Donc il faut être prudent : même les biais implicites peuvent avoir des conséquences.
Si ces questions vous intéressent, je vous encourage à aller lire le billet de blog qui accompagne cette vidéo dans lequel je donne des détails
sur cette étude qui fait quand même 57 pages, qui est très documentée et qui me semble très solide méthodologiquement.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo, n'hésitez pas à partager, vous abonner mettre des coups bleus, tout ça...
Les actualités de la chaîne c'est sur Facebook et sur Twitter, et ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent venir me soutenir sur Tipeee. Merci, à bientôt !